vamos a calcular cuánto tiempo estará
este objeto en el aire si yo les dijera
que algo está viajando hacia arriba a 10
m por
segundo y que la gravedad lo está
desacelerando a 10 m por segundo al
cuadrado es decir que cada segundo este
objeto se va haciendo más lento
eh 10 m por segundo Entonces cuánto
tiempo tardará a que este llegue a una
velocidad cero digamos que inicia a 10 m
por segundo y está involucrada la
gravedad cuánto tiempo tardará para que
este objeto tenga una velocidad igual a
cer0 Bueno le va a tomar exactamente un
segundo ya que tenemos que la gravedad
es igual a -10 m sobre segundo
cuadrado entonces eh Si queremos saber
Eh bueno Desde este momento llega lo
lanzamos le toma un segundo si va a a
una velocidad de 10 m por segundo llegar
a una velocidad cer0 con la gravedad
igual a -10 m por segundo cuadrado y a
su vez le va a tomar otro segundo partir
de cer0 volverse a acelerar con la
gravedad y le tomará otro segundo llegar
de nuevo a una velocidad de -10 m por
segundo si yo quiero saber el tiempo
entonces el tiempo que tarda esto en el
aire tenemos que el
tiempo en el
aire es igual a la velocidad que tiene
este objeto en este ejemplo es 10 m
sobre segundo entre la
aceleración que es 10 m sobre segundo al
cuadrado y esto lo multiplicamos por dos
porque es el tiempo que nos toma de ir
de este una velocidad hasta cero
detenerse y volver de esa velocidad cer0
a
caer si el objeto se estuviera moviendo
hacia arriba a digamos 20 m entonces la
gravedad lo seguiría desacelerando a 10
m por segundo cuadrado Así que este
tiempo le tomaría 2 segundos Así que no
importa cuál sea la velocidad hacia
arriba el tiempo en el aire lo vamos a
escribir en otro color el tiempo en el
aire es igual a nuestra velocidad
vertical o nuestra aceleración o rapidez
per nuestra rapidez vertical
entre la
aceleración multiplicado por 2 asumiendo
que no hay resistencia al
aire bueno Entonces tenemos que
conocemos nuestro componente vertical
SB es ig a s por el seno de teta vamos a
sustituirlo en nuestra fórmula del
tiempo entonces nuestro tiempo en el
aire es igual a s por seno de teta entre
nuestra aceleración que viene siendo la
gravedad multiplicado por
dos y bueno vamos a escribirlo
propiamente lo más adecuado es poner el
dos aquí al principio por la s de
nuestra velocidad del vector nuestra
aceleración Perdón nuestra rapidez del
vector multiplicado por el seno de teta
entre la
gravedad si ustedes me dicen que están
lanzando un objeto digamos a 100 m por
segundo y eh tiene un ángulo de 30 gr
entonces bueno tenemos que el seno de 30
gr es 1/2 así que nos quedaría
2 por eh nuestra velocidad que quedamos
que era 100 m por
segundo por eh 1/2 que es el seno de 30
gr entre nuestra gravedad que son 10 Met
por segundo al
cuadrado para saber exactamente cuánto
tiempo estuvo nuestro proyectil en el
aire